and then I kind of thought to myself
well how do I how do I study Russian
because there were very few schools in
my uh region you know given the
impoverishment of the region where you
could study Russian so I would have to
take Russian from scratch
and this is where things get really
quite interesting
because there were opportunities to
study
um Russian at universities but I would
need to have first of all an intensive
Russian language course in the summer
and I didn't have the money for that
and the period is around the minor
strike in the United Kingdom in 1984.
now the miners of County Durham that
very interestingly had exchanges and
ties with the miners of donbass going
back to the 1920s
and as I studied Russian history I
discovered there was lots of contacts
between you know Bolshevik Soviet Union
the early period after the Russian
Revolution but even before that during
the Imperial period in Russia between
the northern England and the Russian
Empire and the old industrial areas
basically big industrial areas like the
northeast of England and places like Don
bass were built up at the same time
Often by the same sets of industrialists
and danetsk in the donbass region used
to be called husicka because it was
established by a Welsh industrialist who
brought in miners from Wales to help um
you know kind of develop the coal mines
there and also the the steel works and
others that you know were caring about
all the time and so I got very
fascinated in all these linkages and you
know famous writers from the early parts
of the Soviet Union like give Guinea
zamyasin uh worked in the shipyards in
Newcastle upon Tyne and there was just
this whole set of connections
and in 1984
when the miners strike took place the
miners of donbass along with other
miners from famous coal regions like
Duro Valley for example in Germany or
mine is in Poland
sent money in solidarity to the miners
of County Durham and they've been these
exchanges as I said going back and forth
since the 1920s formal exchanges between
miners you know the region the miners
unions
and I um heard again from the same uh
great uncle who told me to study Russian
that there were actually scholarships of
the children of Miners and it could be
former miners as well for their
education and I should go along to the
miners Hall Players called Red Hills
where the the minders of country Durham
had actually pulled all of their
resources and built up their own
Parliament and their own you know kind
of players that they could talk among
themselves to figure out how to enhance
the welfare and well-being of their
communities and they'd put money aside
for education for minors there was all
kinds of lecture series from the miners
and all kinds of other activities
supporting soccer teams and artistic
circles and writing circles for example
people like George Orwell you know were
involved in some of these writers
circles in other parts of Britain and
Mining communities for example and so uh
they told me I could you know go along
and basically apply for a grant to go to
study Russian so I show up and it was
the easiest you know application I've
ever come across that just asked me to
my dad came along with me they asked me
to verify you know that my dad had been
a minor and they looked up his
employment record on little cards you
know kind of a little a little tray
somewhere and then they asked me how
much I needed you know to uh basically
pay for the travel and some of the basic
expenses for the um
the study and they wrote me a check
and so thanks to the miners of donbath
and this money that was deposited with
the miners of uh come to Durham with the
general minders Association I got the
money to study Russian for the first
time uh before I embarked on my studies
at University